were you angry when you started comedy
or did that like develop like did you
have that tense that tension when you
got on stage I wasn't but I also like I
was completely not aware of who I was
when I thought I was like I thought I
was fine I thought my childhood was fine
I thought everything was fine and I got
on stage and then gradually the events
that happened preceding my career
started the wave started crashing on the
beach basically and I and where I ended
up going in life and where the [ __ ] I
was at I got really angry towards like
uh in my 30s and who do you agree I I
was just mad at the world like I was
just an angry guy I wasn't like Lily
Matt literally mad at the world I was
just reacting and anger and everything
and was like like your 20s to me are
like that's you just taken out your
childhood on the world because you don't
know what you're doing he just left your
parents house and now you're just
reacting you know to whatever whatever
happened good or bad and then like in
your 30s that's when as an adult you
have to start [ __ ] looking back at
yourself and that's when I was I started
you know I think when I was like 35 36
and I was single again I'd [ __ ] up
another relationship and I was sleeping
on a futon yeah and I was just kind of
like you know doing the whole pity party
thing and chicks are [ __ ] up and this
business is [ __ ] up and blah blah blah
and I that was one that was sort of it's
never you everything it's everything
around you yeah it's all [ __ ] up bad
yeah when I started to look inward
continue to [ __ ] up for another five
years six seven eight years but it
started tapering back down like it was
sort of a gradual ascent and of [ __ ]
up and then descent we're now so it was
it like comedy it was like there was
some it was everything yeah their life
and then a lot of times the anger would
just come out onstage ah yeah yeah well
this stay actually being onstage was
kind of the place where believe it or
not I was the least angry a lot of times
sometimes you're on stage too and if
you're yelling or you're doing these
characters people think that you're mad
while you're doing it they don't realize
that you're having a great time right
but I think it just yeah
it's sort of 41:42 was when it peaked
and I started to kind of turn it around
it gets exhausting after a while being
angry a lot it's like it's like and I
was always read it's the most immature
knee-jerk emotion to have it doesn't
solve anything and it's really it's a
really immature way of handling [ __ ]
it's right funny to watch
that's great somebody losing this [ __ ]
and uh I actually get a charge out of
watching people lose their [ __ ] because
I so relate to it but um when you take
it home with you and it's in the car
with you it is toxic it's always there I
feel good yeah that's one of the things
that I grew up around a lot of volatile
people and you think in your head I'm
never doing that I'm not going to
associate with people la blah blah than
what it is as you go out in the world
unless you really work that out you just
gravitate towards what is natural which
is why you know all of us lunatics I
think because I think now like we have
really healthy back and forth when I
look back a lot of that [ __ ] at the
table a lot of that was not healthy when
we were sitting to go out with toughen
each other up to go onstage but they're
really just are your anger I used to
[ __ ] go into him and Patrice and
Keith and all those guys who'd be down
there like I remember I would have like
I would be thinking about their faces
and everything and I would I would try
to come up with like three or four
[ __ ] jabs just so I could get to the
seat so I could sit down and it never
dawned on me when it wasn't working for
me because I was really angry back then
to just be like why don't you just not
go there why don't you just sit down in
another table because the way I grew up
was that's what everybody did to
everybody so that was the Thanksgiving
table dude agree I lie when I look back
that we would you know the broken toys
just [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of each other
it was [ __ ] you know it was
definitely fun but there was definitely
times well you know we when I got in a
real argument even trees got real
arguments you you got into a people
Bobby got into people like it would it
would then mean Bobby had a real one
recently we yell at each other but
that's part of being friends with Bob
though
yeah you know that's gonna I guess I'd
say what the Bobby's good that he calls
each I did look bad he calls you the
next day like he reached out you know
and I guess you're never one of the best
Bobby Kelly stories I have one time we
were taking the subway uptown
and he was talking about the business
and everything and I thought I was
actively listening and Ingo yeah blah
blah I don't know what I was doing so he
was going to help me with my computer so
he was going to my apartment so we were
walking down the street it's like the
middle of the afternoon
and in my head I just have tuned him out
because I started thinking like well
this is [ __ ] up because he used to
live right next to me he's gonna go all
the way up to my apartment to fix my
computer why don't I just run up and get
the computer and I'll bring it down to
his I was trying to make his life easier
so I was thinking about that you know
which goes back to the whole Catholic
guilt of like oh oh something's going to
be handling my needs I and I gotta be
more operation cancer so I guess I guess
I wasn't listening I have no idea so he
was in the middle of talking and as he
was talking I just go hey Bob I'm just
gonna run up and grab a few and he's the
top of his lungs broad daylight with
buildings on either side so it echoed he
just goes don't interrupt me [ __ ]
hop of his [ __ ] lungs like dude I'm
telling you huh what'd I tell you dude
out of [ __ ] nowhere like he was
totally talking you know my agent I just
feel like they're not sending me out
enough and I just in the top of it and
he just [ __ ] went from zero to a
thousand hahaha and people like
strollers [ __ ] looking around and
[ __ ] and I just looked at my just I just
actually first summary because I was
getting older than I just remain calm I
said I just said Bob I thought we were
past this and then he sort of had a
smirk on his face and then it just sort
of just stopped and then we went up we
fixed the computer but it but it was
still dysfunctional because I don't
think we quite addressed it right but I
just said I thought we were past this
and then he tried to still kind of and
then he just had nothing because I
didn't react to it the whole [ __ ]
thing went away but it was just like
that's great
like that's great yeah I'll never forget
that and we were I remember exactly the
thought we were not even you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was so like don't interrupt me
just [ __ ] like oh I mean it probably
made it to the Hudson dude it was
[ __ ] it was amazing sure it was
actually it was a performance piece so I
whenever I look back on it I
laughs and then emotional uh like going
like I can go like I went I went zero mm
like I'm really good with traffic now
but like you know when I was just like
you know watching this [ __ ] thing is
it's it's getting you there like I was
the mistake I was make I put in Sirius
XM it for my place it said it's going to
take 31 minutes but I forget that's at 8
o'clock and then I leave at 8:15 and now
it's saying 40 I'm like I'll [ __ ] now
I'm not going to get there until like
you know 8:50 and then you're driving
then such going 851 852 851 854 9
o'clock it fit in and then it just
starts building up I just started
thinking like I finally was just able to
say in my head like you know if I get
there at 9:05 are they really gonna
[ __ ] flip out I'll be fine we're
doing yeah we're gonna be fine
everything's me fine wait what did Bobby
say to you what about say when you asked
about me your computer when you're like
when you were like hey I'm just gonna go
upstairs and get the component don't
interrupt me cuz
let's get me V laugh all day